this is not juggling this is called
misdirection
[Music]
and no matter what level you are at
magic we got stuff here for you
learning basic principles of magic like
learning chords on a guitar once you
know a few simple principles
you can build your whole magic routine
and if you're smart enough to work
silently it brings out a huge amount of
wonder
when when you don't talk the audience
has to tell itself the story and they
don't know where it's going
the basic method behind this uses sound
misdirection
uh palming is when you hide something in
your hand you're going to bring your
whole hand around to conceal that ball
and completely close your fist
and that will make all your relatives
laugh
the simplest trick you can do involves
exploring
how do we know what is true take those
two ends and tie them in a double knot
around each other
yeah i'll see you later
there's more magic in cards than
anything else you don't need to know the
car you just have to
know the card next to the card was that
your card
if you get good at magic you will
automatically get good at a certain kind
of acting
magic forces you to learn about
storytelling
assumptions about the way we perceive
the world
and then smash it that's it you must be
empathetic
you must try to see yourself through
another person's eyes
and i think you have to simply say that
one of the
things that makes life worth living is
giving other people joy
we're pen and teller and this is our
master class
you